This video continues my series about the
various types of regular sound changes
that happen over time in language.
Last time we considered situations where
existing sounds became more or less
similar to one another.
Assimilation and dissimilation.
This time it's all about sounds that
get added to or deleted from words.
When a sound is added to a word
that's called a parenthesis.
The new phoneme is an empathetic sound.
For instance,
you may have heard some English speakers
add an epithetic are to the word
Sherbet pronouncing it Sherbert.
Not all added sounds of the same
is the additional sound of vowel.
That's an up Texas Sardinian speakers
changed Rosa to outer Rosa by adding an an
up tick.
Tick Val to the front of the word
is the edit sound. That consonant
if so, that's called excrescence.
Ancient Greek speakers
sometimes pronounced their
word st as as team adding an
excrescence consonant.
Not all in parenthesis happens in the
same place either if the phoneme is added
to the beginning of a word,
it's called pro thesis.
The Sardinian example at
Rosa adds a pathetic APP.
If the phoneme is added to the end
of a word, it's called paragogy.
The ancient Greek word esteem
as a pair of [inaudible], n
Elysian happens when a sound
is removed from a word.
The last phoneme is said
to be elided or deleted.
The final book sound has been
alighted from the English word thumb.
Compare the book and thimble.
Okay.
Is the phoneme removed from the
beginning of a word? That's a Ferris.
For example, English speakers may
shorten about time too. About time.
Is this sound removed
from the middle of award?
This kind of allision is known as syncope.
This we send you a word,
meaning the bears is pronounced
[inaudible] speakers.
Cinco paid that middle.
Who
is the phoneme removed
from the end of a word?
That change gets called a pocket.
So the word thumb,
losing its final bow over time
is an example of a pocket.
So this has been a quick
ground level understanding
of a pen stasis and allision.
In the next video,
I'll pick out a few types of sound
changes we haven't seen so far.